bonsoir gérard lolivier merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous clairement joe biden va
devoir gérer ce dossier cubain qui
n'était pas une priorité pour lui oui
bonsoir
non non je n'ai pas du tout une priorité
la preuve c'est que son administration
avait laissé en place les sanctions qui
avaient été réintroduites vers la fin de
l'administration donald trump
il faut rappeler très brièvement que les
relations entre les etats-unis et cuba
roux était pratiquement gelée de 1960 à
2015 d'abord du fait de la guerre froide
et puis après du fait que cuba a trouvé
un nouvel allié avec le venezuela et que
les états unis ont maintenu une
politique d'embargo visant à faire
tomber le régime de l'intérieur en
quelque sorte les sens que cela produise
des faits c'est le président obama qui
avait changé cette politique à partir de
on avait parlé à des tombes de déchets
le dégel cubain il avait levé l'embargo
il avait rétabli des relations
commerciales des états unis ont ouvert
une ambassade à cuba en 2015 il ya eu la
fameuse visite du président obama en
mars 2016 à cuba première visite d'un
président américain en plus de 81 ans et
depuis les choses allaient beaucoup
mieux au sein de l'île si ce n'est que
les républicains et en particulier
donald trump ont jugé que les américains
avaient ouvert le robinet permettant au
régime et à l'économie cubaine d'aller
beaucoup mieux sans pour autant que le
régime évolué dans sa promotion des
droits de l'homme son respect des droits
de l'homme sa promotion des libertés
individuelles même des liberté
d'entreprendre des libertés économiques
qui fait que vers la fin de son mandat
donald trump a rétabli un certain nombre
de sanctions en particulier il a rétabli
la liste de cuba enfin la présence de
cuba sur la liste des états considérés
comme sponsor du terrorisme
il a interdit les transferts d'argent
des états unis.vers cubain ce qui a
provoqué une crise économique quasiment
instantané à cuba cela cumulé avec le co
vide
on a aujourd'hui la situation que l'on
constate mais l'administration byden
quand elle est arrivée elle n'a ri
un fait pour revenir sur les positions
prises par l'administration trump est en
quelque sorte
elle attendait de voir donc c'est une
crise en effet qu'elle ne souhaitait pas
avoir à traiter selon donald trump un
joe biden doit s'opposer jeu suite au
régime communiste sinon dit-il histoire
s'en rappellera qu est ce que ça veut
dire concrètement est ce qu'il y aurait
du vrai devant ce diagnostic
ce que ça rappelle c'est que
l'opposition entre cuba et les etats
unis c'est une opposition qui est ancré
dans la guerre froide
il faut rappeler que cubain c'est le
première je dirais incidents de de
l'impérialisme en quelque sorte des
états unis les relations entre cuba et
les etats unis remonte au 19e siècle
les etats-unis ont soutenu cuba dans sa
guerre de libération contre l'espagne
l'espoir à l'époque était que cuba a
intégré le giron américain des états
unis avaient cherché à acheter lille
plusieurs fois à l'espagne sans succès
les cubains ont préféré leur
indépendance et ils l'ont obtenue sous
une forme de protectorat américain
protectorat dans le cadre duquel les
américains ont hérité de cette fameuse
base à guantanamo avec un bail
renouvelable de 99 ans et qui est
aujourd'hui deuxième fois séculaire donc
il y avait cette relation je dirais de
clients entre les etats-unis et cuba une
relation qui s'est envenimée avec la
présidence de batista dans les années 50
et quand fidel castro est arrivé les
américains ont laissé batista tomber
espérant sans doute faire tomber castro
derrière malheureusement castro s'est
réfugiée dans les bras de l'union
soviétique alors et on a eu une
situation entre autres la fameuse crise
des missiles cubains durant laquelle le
monde est passé à quelques à quelques
doigts on va dire quelques centimètres
de la crise thermonucléaire comme on
disait à l'époque les et les relations
entre les deux pays ont alors étaient
gelés et les etats unis ont toujours agi
sur la base que cuba était un régime
communiste et que le devoir des états
unis était de s'opposer à tout régime
communiste de touche r
pour qu'il y ait un changement de régime
sur place donc la politique du président
obama qui consistait à chercher à faire
une sorte de je dirais travail et de
l'intérieur
laissez le régime s'ouvrir à travers une
forme d'ouverture économique devait
déboucher sur une ouverture politique
quand cela n'a pas fonctionné et qu'au
contraire on a assisté
pas plus tard d'ailleurs que ce
printemps je rappelle qu'il y a eu un
congrès un congrès du parti communiste
cuba autre attente qui a confirmé la
présidence de monsieur miguel diaz
cannelle à la présidence comme
successeur des frères castro est une
sorte de je dirais pérennisation du
régime
à partir de là les etats-unis sont dans
leurs droits historiques de chercher à
faire tomber ce régime puisque ils se
sont toujours opposés au communisme
partout où il cherchait à s'étendre
merci beaucoup gérald ollivier
journaliste franco américain cherchera
lips merci d'avoir été avec nous ils
nous avoir apporté votre analyse